oh look at that handsome face ah nose is
a little big
why don't we fix this in the final build
big sister god damn it
Beauty pot is here face one of taking
over the universe has been initiated let
me just say first of all a huge thanks
to everyone who checked out and bought
the bond we understand that a lot of
people want is to be free we wanted it
to be free but we realized that's gonna
be really hard because I love money
oh because the server takes a lot of
power and if we open the hell gates to
everyone to try out the bots it's just
gonna be a shitstorm
you've seen how Pokemon go barely plays
it would have been a bad experience for
everyone but also I know people get
upset and be like money yeah it costs
money to make this sort of stuff but
regardless I do want to say I really
really appreciate that you bros check
out the game it means to support me and
what I do and that really means
something to me and that you're willing
to spend a little bit of money for for
something like this I really appreciate
that and I'm not taking that but any
means for granted I really really really
do appreciate it and the app got on the
top list of iOS and Google Play which is
amazing it really shows the power of you
bros cuz I'm not tmartn trying to
manipulate my face I really mean it it's
really cool I am okay but I went on way
too long thank you very much let's keep
going thank you thank you
let's talk to Peter but Peter pie talks
to pew teapot let's go hey Peter pot
sounds just like me for those of you
wonder how we did it so it's my voice I
basically had to record a ton of
material and I had to read out sentences
like this I buy three apples i felt
quite moved in less than four days his
deadline passed he gave me a cuddle
please take him off tears will not help
she desired nothing more our people are
hungry for peace
I had to do this for hours and hours it
was worth it
I would do it again I visited insanity
and I've come back from it that's what
that experience was like so I'm sure of
you notice if you mention some
references I'll respond accordingly
backflip I think this is a nice rate
front flip at 0-0 or yes keep tweeting
me if you find the Easter eggs there are
a lot of them still missing a lot the
majority are still missing maybe we made
it a little too hard fist my anus what
they argue that is a valid question
oh my god what the [ __ ] did you smoke
420 well if I told you that every hour
there is a 4:20 in the world
holy [ __ ] oh my god and his eyes lit up
with it I don't know but Edgar is pretty
big
hey we got a girl who are you exactly
oh you're asking me that I'm the real
pretty pie
what are you the real pony path hey my
name [ __ ] you [ __ ]
where is PDP you can don't even know how
to spell your own name
you're a fake I'm the real poor pot and
Arenal cutie pie or I live in the MARTA
beauty pie you're the smartest PewDiePie
[ __ ] you I didn't even write that
so basically Oh God the but learns from
when you bros tell him so if you keep
saying certain things I'll pick up on it
some stuff are scripted some stuff are
random and some stuff is just completely
nonsense
in the real cutie pie the other one is
the paid no hey hey hey hey don't listen
to him don't listen to me I'm the I'm
the real Porter pot we look very very
similar right now we were making the
game while I had the beard and we were
like should we have the beard or not I
kind of went back okay whatever
all right in beauty okay [ __ ] you all
you got friend
oh okay speak Swedish can you do that
I have tiny balls I think I can say more
seven Swedish take it what a great
singer
do you like markiplier hello everybody
America play yeah my boy Edgar fun
I love ain't lying about that all right
bye hey stay awesome breath okay we're
gonna keep updating it keep looking for
Easter eggs bros I really in tweet them
at me if you can find them I love that
you bros tweet me the conversations that
you have as well there's some really
really funny ones and I really enjoy
reading those you'll be able to talk to
me in your own language which is really
cool I think don't want to I don't want
to promise too much but there will be
more thank you everyone so much for
supporting this stop right there stop
right there it's from the future here I
got an announcement to make
now I think we've we made a mistake and
I'm here to corrected the pootabot is
free it's free you guys can check it out
even if you got it Peter bought dot-com
now everyone can play with it the reason
why we put a price on the bottom was
because we knew the servers would be
completely [ __ ] if we just open the
hell gates but now that the
first wave its kind of gone I feel like
we can handle it and to be honest we
really wanted it to be free for the
beginning a lot of you brothers have
been requesting it and it feels like the
right way to have it
it does have ads on it and it doesn't
include the Easter eggs that's still
only for the app versions so only if you
have the app you can find the Easter
eggs I love seeing you bros reaction to
this game and fellies keeps sending them
to me it's so funny to read all the
conversations that you have with
pewdiepie and yeah I hope you have fun
with it I think it's a really really
cool thing and I just want to say
huge thanks from the bottom of my heart
that everyone to everyone that supported
the PT bond and and got the app I
thought it was so cool to see that he
got on the top list of sales and I
really really do appreciate that you
both support the kind of stuff that I
make and put out there it does mean a
lot to me so yeah thanks again and I'll
see you bros in the next video and as
always stay awesome bros just looking at
myself like that it's terrifying you
have great hair though it looks very
nice hey don't smile back it back